ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HIM.
BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH BURKE. CALDERON
CARRILLO. CERVANTES CHAU. CHEN
CHIU. CHOI COOLEY. COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG ASURE FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL- SEN PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK PERKS SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE TíNH
RELATIVE AREAS VIA PUMA VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DAZE PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. AND THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. OH MY GOD. THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE SUFFERING.
THERE ARE SINGLE PARENTS THAT
ARE WORKING VERY HARD. AND ARE
STILL STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. THERE ARE CALIFORNIANS
THERE ARE FOOD INSECURE. NEARLY
ONE OUT OF SIX CALIFORNIANS
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. USE
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US ON THIS
FLOOR. TO BRING EASE AND HOPE
TO ALL THOSE THAT NEED. USE US
FOR YOUR WORK I MEAN. THANK YOU
MOM YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN DR QUIRK AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
DOCTOR. REALLY AGAIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
STATE. G. YEAH. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY SCHIRMER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
REDDIT NINETY M. THE HONORABLE
REBEKAH BAUR QUE HANNAH SYSTEM
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
SUPERCOPA DE ESPA READING FOR
DAVID ONLY READING THE ROLES
CALL MS REYES SAID MR LARA
SECONDS. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE- TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KALRA.
IN CUNNINGHAM. MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THEY ARE TWO
WEEKS IN THIS AREA TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA IS
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE ITEM EIGHT THREE. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ARAMBULA
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. I
REQUEST WILL NOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THIS JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA
THE FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
TO ALLOW THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE FOLLOWING
BILLS AT THEIR HEARING TODAY
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
THERE IS A LIST OF THESE BILLS
AT THE DESK AND I ALSO THE
CLERK READ THE MEASURE. CALGARY
SOME PEOPLE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
POWER QUE HAN ASSEMBLY WILL SIX
SIXTY ONE BENNET ASSEMBLY WILL
THIRTY SEVEN BERMAN SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY SIX BERMAN
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY ONE
BELOW CYNICAL LEVIN TWENTY SIX
BLOOM SO MICHAEL TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE BLOOM ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA SOME LEGAL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX CARILLO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FIVE
TWO SOME PEOPLE FIVE FIFTY TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTEEN CHU
ASSEMBLY GO NINE THIRTY FOUR
COOLEY SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
NINE FLOOR SOME PEOPLE TO FONG
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE SEVEN NINE
FRAZIER SO WE WILL NINE EIGHTY
ONE FRAZIER SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE FRAZIER.
ASSEMBLY ROLE LEVIN FORTY SEVEN
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY ROLLOVER
NINETY FIVE CRISTINA GARCIA
SOME PEOPLE SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
EDUARDO GARCIA SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED EDUARDO GARCIA
ASSEMBLY GO TO FIFTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ SOME LEGAL SEVEN A ONE
GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY RELIVING
THIRTY NINE GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY
WILL THIRTEEN NINETEEN GONZALEZ
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN FIFTY THREE
GRAYSON SO WE WILL LIVE IN
THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON ASSEMBLY GO
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE HOLDEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETEEN OR
WHEN SOMEONE GO FOR SIXTEEN
KALRA ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
NINE FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT LEVINE ASSEMBLY
RELIVING NINETY FOUR LOW
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT LOW ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY NINE MATHIS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY SIX MATHIS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FORTY SIX MAYES.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY NINE
MCCARTY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN MCCARTY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT MULLIN
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN THIRTY
SEVEN MULLIN ASSEMBLY WILL
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE FOR SUSHI
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
THIS AREA ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY
PETRIE-NORRIS SOME AGO FIVE
FORTY FIVE COURT ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SIXTY TWO PORK SILVA
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
CORRECT SILVA ASSEMBLY BILL
LEVIN EIGHTY THREE RAMOS SOME
PEOPLE FOR TWELVE REYES
ASSEMBLY GO NINE EIGHTY FOUR
THREE OF US ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS SOME
AGO FIVE SIXTY EIGHT ROBERT
RIVAS ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN TEN
ROBERT RIVAS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO RODRIGUEZ SOME
LEGAL EIGHT SEVEN ON RUBIO.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
RUBIO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE
SALAS SOME PEOPLE SIX NINETY
NINE SALAS SOME AGO FIFTEEN OH
THREE SANTIAGO ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHTEEN SO
MICHAEL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
TEN. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD. ALSO PEOPLE
NINE FORTY WORK. AS A BOTH
ELEVEN TWO WERE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOR L. WOULD SOMEONE WILL SAY
NINETY. COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS OR
PROFESSION. ASSEMBLY WILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS IMPRESSIONS. THAT'S
FOR DAVID WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING COLLABORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 440-236-5716
317-588-5010 301-764-1150.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO ELEVEN NINETY
TWELVE TWENTY ONE TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE TWELVE THIRTY NINE
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE THREE THIRTY NINE
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN FIVE FIFTY
NINE SEVEN FIFTY FOUR THIRTEEN
OH TWO THIRTEEN NINETY TH
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX
AND ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ. AND ALL AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP THE AMENDMENTS
FIRST. ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. YEAH. BEGINNING WITH.
FILE ITEM. THIRTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY THREE
WITH A MINUTES BY SOME RICHARD
MEMBERS. MEMBERS ARE TAKING UP
AMENDMENTS. MISTER Q. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS FOR EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE A BILL THAT
CONTINUES COUNTY THIRTY FOR
REMOTE MARRIAGE LICENSE SCENE
OF THE AMENDMENTS TO TWO THINGS
WE ADDED URGENCY CLAUSE TO
ENSURE CONTINUOUS SERVICE BY
COUNTIES FOR CALIFORNIANS THAT
WANT TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF.
THESE POSSIBILITIES AND THEN
SECONDLYWE TRANSFER LEAD
AUTHORSHIP TO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE GOOD IN A GAL ASSET
THESE BE ADOPTED AND THAT THE
BILL BE SENT TO PRINT AND PUT
BACK ON FIVE. DAVID CHIU MISS
DAVIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR INTEREST ME
IN THIS BILL. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND- HOPEFULLY
WE'LL SEE IF THE SUCCESSFUL
PASSAGE OF WITH FIVE EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK
YOU MISS DAVIS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AS HAVING
THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS
OUT TO PRINT. THE END BACK ON
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY.
AVERAGE THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
AB THREE THIRTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK DR PARK ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
THREE THIRTY TWO AUTHORIZES
TREATED WOOD WASTE TO BE
MANAGED UNDER ALTERNATIVE
MANAGEMENT STANDARDS INSTEAD OF
MANAGED AS A HAZARDOUS WASTE.
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
REQUIREMENTS ON THE TREATED
WOOD WASTE INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
CONSUMERS AND THEY HAVE
LEGISLATIVE. INTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TO WORK THE
ADMIN AND THE FEW. WANT TREATED
WITH WASTE IS MANAGED I WOULD
THAT AMENDMENTS A DA. THANK YOU
DR WORK. C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE
ON THE OF OBJECTION MAY TAKE A
VOICE ON THESE MEN ALTHOUGH IN
FAVOR AYE. HYPO SAY NAY THE ICE
IT THE MAN ARE JOB. BILLS OUT
TO PRINT BACK OFF. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY SIX BERMAN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH THE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY SIX
WITH MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
BERMAN MR BERMAN ON A MOMENT'S
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWO THIRTY SIX
REQUIRES A LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY THAT MAKES
CONTRIBUTIONS OR EXPENDITURES
IN CONNECTION WITH CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
THE IDENTITIES. OF SPECIFIED
MEMBERS OF THE L. L. C. THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL BY RAISING CERTAIN
DISCLOSURE THRESHOLDS AND
SHORTENING THE LOOK BACK PERIOD
FOR DETERMINING WHICH MEMBERS
OF AN LLC MUST BE PUBLICLY
DISCLOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ADDITIONALLY DELETE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
CODIFIED REGULATIONS THAT WERE
RECENTLY ADOPTED BY THE F. B.
P. C. I. S. AT THE AMENDMENTS
TO BE ADOPTED AND THAT THE BILL
BE SENT OUT TO PRINT AND PLACE
BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN. SENIOR DISCUSSION ON
THE MEMON SAID WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING UP
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO FORTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF A MEMORY WITH A
MEDICINE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY TWO WITH THE MINUTES BY
SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN. MISTER
HOLD ON A MOMENT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE DEMAND AB
TWO FORTY TO OUR ANNUAL PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE CLEANUP BILL
THESE AMENDMENTS MAKE A MINOR
CHANGE TO THE DATE RETAIL
ELECTRICITY SUPPLIERS DISCLOSE
INFORMATION TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
UNDER THE POWER SOURCE
DISCLOSURE PROGRAM TO ALIGN
WITH CURRENT PRACTICE.
COLLEAGUES ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN. SEE
NO DISCUSSION ON THE AMENDMENTS
ARE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. YES SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED. BILLS UP PRINTED BACK
ON FILE. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM. ONE HUNDRED FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
HOLDEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF A
MEMBERS COURT AGREED ITH THE
MAN ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN WITH A MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER HOLDEN. MR HOLDING YOU
MAY GET OVER TWENTY MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
PERCENT AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY SEVEN TODAY.
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL
CLARIFY THAT I BIG MAY FINANCE
HOUSING AS A PART OF IT
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PROJECT ONLY
WHEN THE HOUSING ELEMENT IS
REQUIRED. FOR THE OPERATION OF
THE PROJECT. THE MMS WILL
PROHIBIT THE USE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STATE REVOLVING
FUND TO FUND. THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PORTION OF THE PROJECT.
THESE CHANGES WERE RECOMMENDED
BY THE ASSEMBLY JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT
LIMITED INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS.
STAY DEDICATED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
HOLDEN SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY
THE EYES HAVE IT THE MANSARD
OPTED BILLS UP FRONT TO BACK ON
FILE.
MEMBERS THIS IS MOVING
BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE MEMBERS. MEMBERS
OF THE VOLUME OF A MANAGEABLE
PLEASE WE ARE STILL ON
AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE. BY MS WICKS COURT AGREED
WITH THE MENACE. SOME PEOPLE
FOR FIFTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
BY SOME MEMBER WICKS THIS MAKES
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE 2% EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY IN
CONSULTATION WITH CALTRANS TO
ESTABLISH TRAFFIC LANES. FOR
TRANSIT AND SPECIFIC HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLES ON THE BAY
BRIDGE CORNER DURING PEAK
HOURS. THE PURPOSES OF THESE
ELEMENTS ARE TO CHANGE THE
BILL'S AUTHOR FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA TO MYSELF IN
LIGHT OF HIS RECENT DESIGNATION
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL. THANK YOU
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS.
C. NOTIFICATION RATE ON THE
MEMINTA WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
WE ARE TAKING UP A COUPLE OF
HOUSE RESOLUTIONS.
MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM ONE
AWAIT. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
AWAIT. HR FORTY THREE. CORKERY
HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO HARVEY MILK DAY.
OKAY MILWAUKEE MELVIN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR FORTY THREE TODAY
WE HONOR HARVEY MILK A HERO IN
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY HARVEY WAS
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN CALIFORNIA AND OF
ANY MAJOR UNITED STATES CITY A
GLOBAL ICON AND A PIONEER IN
THE LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
THIS WASN'T ALWAYS THE CASE NOW.
HARVEY WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IN
SEVERAL LOCAL ELECTIONS BEFORE
HE WON A SEAT ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. IS UNPRECEDENTED VICTORY
AND THE WAVES HE MADE IN JUST
ONE YEAR CONTINUE TO INSPIRE US
TODAY. WORKING TO FIGHT
HOMOPHOBIA AND OTHER FORMS OF
LGBTQ DISCRIMINATION MILK WAS
OFTEN THE LOUDEST VOICE AT A
TIME WHEN MANY WERE AFRAID TO
BE THEMSELVES. HE ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGED MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY TO SHOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHO THEY WERE AND
EXPRESS THEIR TRUE IDENTITIES.
HARVEY'S LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY
CUT SHORT WHEN A FORMER
COLLEAGUE ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ASSASSINATED HIM
ALONG WITH SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
GEORGE MOSCONI. HARVEY'S KILLER
WAS CONVICTED OF MANSLAUGHTER
INSTEAD OF MURDER AND INJUSTICE
THAT SPARKED RIOTS. THE OUTCOME
OF THAT TRIAL SERVES AS A STARK
REMINDER THAT WE MUST ALWAYS BE
VIGILANT IN MAKING SURE THAT
EQUITY IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
PRESENT. HARVEY WON SAID. I
KNOW YOU CAN'T LIVE ON HOPE
ALONE. BUT WITHOUT HOPE LIFE IS
NOT WORTH LIVING. IN A WORLD
WHERE WE HAVE YET TO ENSURE
EQUALITY FOR ALL HARVEY'S
IMPACT AS A TRAILBLAZER AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATE CATALYZE
POLICY INSPIRED PEOPLE TO COME
OUT AND TO BE THEMSELVES TO RUN
FOR OFFICE AND TO BE AT THE
TABLE. HE STILL MOVES US TO
CONTINUE THE FIGHT FOR WHAT HE
STARTED I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE IS PARA QUE HAND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
FIFTY THREE. I WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBER FROM SILICON VALLEY
FOR BRINGING IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND THE MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR SPEAKING SO ELOQUENTLY ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF IT. TODAY WE
CELEBRATE AND COMMEMORATE THE
PIONEERING LIFE AND CAREER OF
HARVEY MILK. HARVEY MILK WAS A
MIDDLE CLASS JEWISH KID FROM
NEW YORK. WHOSE GRANDFATHER
FOUNDED A SYNAGOGUE. THEY'RE
NOT RELIGIOUS HE SPOKE YIDDISH
WITH FRIENDS AND EVEN
CONSIDERED OPENING A JEWISH
DELI IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND IS
ALL THE BARE MEMBERS KNOW WE
WOULD APPRECIATED THAT MANY
YEARS BEFORE IT HAPPENED. HE
MADE HISTORY IS ONE OF THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN HE WON HIS SEAT ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. EVEN
IN HIS SHORT CAREER IN POLITICS
HE MADE HISTORIC STRIDES.
FIGHTING FOR EQUAL TREATMENT
AND RAISING THE FIGHT FOR LGBTQ
RIGHTS WHEN THEY WERE UNDER
BRUTAL ATTACK. HARVEY MILK
EMBODIES THE JEWISH VALUES OF
HEALING THE WORLD OF
QUESTIONING ON JUST TO FORTY.
AND ADVOCATING FIERCELY. HE
WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR GAY RIGHTS AND FOR
ALL MNORITY GROUPS FACING
DISCRIMINATION. SIR ON THIS
GREEN CARPET. JUST TWO YEARS
BEFORE HE WAS MURDERED. HE WAS
A LEADER LIKE SO MANY OF US
HERE. WHO RESPONDED TO THE
OUTCRY OF HIS COMMUNITY. DRIVEN
BY HIS VALUES. BEGINNING A
POLITICAL CAREER YOUNG. AND
HAVING IT ENDED WAY TOO EARLY.
WE CANNOT LET THE FORCES OF
HATE SHAKE US FROM OUR
DEDICATION TO THE JUSTICE I
HEARD SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE
TO REMIND US OF WHY WE FIGHT.
TO HONOR HARVEY MILK AS A
LEGENDARY FIGHTER WHO THIS
CHAMBER WOULD HAVE BEEN HONORED
TO HAVE STAND AMONG US I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR FORTY THREE. NAME IS
BURKE HAND MR MCCARTY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF OUR BLACK
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I ALSO RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR FORTY
THREE TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR
HARVEY MILK DAY ON WHICH WOULD
BE HIS NINETY FIRST BIRTHDAY.
THIS SATURDAY HIS LEGACY AS A
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER AN LGBTQ
ACTIVIST AND ICON IS STILL FELT
TODAY. HE SAID ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL NO MATTER HOW
HARD THEY TRY THEY CAN NEVER
ERASE THOSE WORDS THAT IS WHAT
AMERICA IS ABOUT AND THAT
CERTAINLY SIMILAR WITH THEIR-
BLACK. EXPERIENCE ACROSS
AMERICAN OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT HERE IN OUR COUNTRY
AND STATE AS WELL. THROUGH HIS
COMPASSION AND PERSEVERANCE
MISTER MILK DID EVERYTHING IN
HIS POWER TO MAKE THE STATE AND
COUNTRY LIVE UP TO THOSE WORDS.
HE IS KNOWN AS THE MOST
PROLIFIC FIGURE IN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY IN THIS PATH TO
OFFICE WAS NOT EASY. LIKE MANY
AND OTHER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES HE EXPERIENCE
PREJUDICE DISCRIMINATION AND
THREATS OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
BUT PERSEVERED. I WILL NOTE AS
WE KNOW. AS WE GRAPPLE WITH
SOME HOT ISSUES AN IMPORTANT
ISSUES. OF BLACK AMERICAN BLACK
CALIFORNIA DAY ONE BEING POLICE
VIOLENCE AND POLICE REFORM- MR
MILKEN MR MOSCONI WERE IN THE
FOREFRONT RIGHT BEFORE HIS
ASSASSINATION LEADING ON WHAT
ISSUE. POLICE REFORM IN HIS
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HONOR HIS
LEGACY. AND THE BLACK CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS CERTAINLY KNOW
THE MOVEMENTS THAT HE LED AND
PERSEVERED TODAY I WITH THAT
MISTER SPEAKER I ASKED WE HAD
DURING HIS IN AN HONOR- HARVEY
MILK DAY. THIS WEEKEND. THANK
YOU MISTER CARTER THIS PROVIDES.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHURCH. YOUR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
A PROUD KOBACH THERE. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF H. R. FORTY THREE
COMMEMORATING HARVEY MILK DAY.
FOR ALL G. B. T. Q. PEOPLE
COMING OUT IS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP IN LIVING FREELY AND
AUTHENTICALLY A SPIRIT THAT
HARVEY MILK EMBODIED. HE SERVED
AS A TRAILBLAZER A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. MAYBE VETERAN
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND A
POLITICIAN. THE SPARK UNITY
AROUND THE WORLD. DURING THE
TIME OF IT. AND WITHIN THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE L. G. B.
MOVEMENT AT HARVEY MILK USE HIS
INTELLIGENCE HIS WILL TO LEAD.
AN INFECTIOUS PERSONALITY. TO
BE. YOU BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
TO STAND AGAINST ANTI LGBTQ
HATRED. AS IS ACTIVISM INCREASE
HE BELIEVED THAT IN ORDER TO
CREATE CHANGE YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BE AT THE CENTER OF THE
POLITICAL REFORM HE KNEW THAT
HE HAD TO USE HIS VOICE AS A
PATHWAY FOR LGBTQ CANDIDATES TO
RUN FOR ELECTED OFFICE HER
REMARK WAS AN ADVOCATE NOT ONLY
FOR LGBTQ POPULATION BUT FOR
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR AND OTHER
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. THE
CALIFORNIA WHAT NEXT LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ENCOMPASSES A DOCTOR
OF HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL I NEXT
FOLKS REPRESENTING THE GREAT
EXPERIENCE AND DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA FROM ACTIVE MILITARY
SERVICE PUBLIC SERVANTS
CORPORATE LEADERS BUT THE YOU
KNOW- G. B. T. Q. INDIVIDUALS
ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN LEADING
A NEW AGE IN CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP. THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THE L. G. B. T. Q. AND
WHAT NEXT COMMUNITIES.
HISTORICALLY ARE CONTINUE TO BE
A VITAL OF. HISTORY AND I.
FURTHERMORE IF THERE'S ONE
THING THAT COULD HAVE BEEN NINE
HAS TAUGHT US. WOMEN HAVE BORNE
THE BRUNT OF THE SO. THE SAME
STRUGGLE. REFLECTING ON THE
LIFE OF HER BE MELT AND AS AN
ATTEMPT TO HONOR HIS LIFE.
STAYING COMMITTED TO ADVANCING
SOLUTIONS TO BUILD BACK BETTER
IS VITAL TO ADDRESSING SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES THAT HAVE STARKLY
HELD BACK WOMEN ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF COLOR. THIS FLOOR IS A
SMALL EXAMPLE OF THE DIVERSITY
THAT MAKES UP CALIFORNIA A TRUE
DEFINITION OF DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES COMING TOGETHER TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS OVERCOME
BARRIERS AND IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I LIKE TO THINK
THAT HARVEY MILK WOULD BE A
PROUD. OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE
HAVE MADE. AND I WAS THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY LGBTQ MILLENNIAL
REPRESENTING MY DISTRICT I AM
EXTREMELY HONORED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY COMMEMORATING HARD ENOUGH
DAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS
CERVANTES MYSTERY THAT'S YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN IT
HAS BEEN SAID THAT SOME PEOPLE
ARE BORN BEFORE THEIR TIME-
THAT THE WORLD ISN'T READY FOR
HOW THEY THINK. OR WHO THEY ARE
BRAVE ENOUGH TO BE. BUT HARVEY
MILK ARRIVE JUST WHEN WE NEEDED
THE MOST. AND BEFORE HE WAS
GONE TOO SOON HE WAS THERE IN
THE FIGHT INSPIRING A MOVEMENT
NOT A MINUTE TOO LATE. HE
CHALLENGE CALIFORNIA TO BLAZE A
NEW TRAIL. A TRAIL BASED ON
EQUALITY COMPASSION AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL. CALIFORNIA IS
CONSIDERED A VANGUARD STATE.
AND BECAUSE THE VISIONARIES
LIKE HARVEY MILK. AND I KNOW
THAT THIS DIVERSE LEGISLATURE
WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP HARVEY'S
MISSION ALIVE. WE WILL WORK TO
ENSURE THAT HOPE IS NEVER
EXTINGUISHED HERE IN OUR GOLDEN
STATE. AND WE KNOW THAT WE
STILL WORK TO DO TO ACHIEVE
FULL EQUALITY. THERE ARE STILL
TOO MANY L. G. B. T.
CALIFORNIANS WHO FALL ASLEEP
EVERY NIGHT. WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR FUTURE WORRIED ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'LL BE
ACCEPTED BY THEIR FAMILIES BY
THEIR FRIENDS BY THEIR
COWORKERS AND THE CLASSMATES.
TOO MANY LGBT YOUTH EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AND FACE EXTREME
BULLYING IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND WE
KNOW THAT LGBT RESIDENTS LIVING
IN RURAL PARTS OF OUR STATE.
OFTEN DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO ACHIEVE THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL. L. LGBT
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN IN ALL
CORNERS OF OUR STATE NORTH AND
SOUTH. EAST AND WEST IN
COUNTIES LARGE AND SMALL. IN
EVERY TOWN AND CITY SHOULD HAVE
SIMILAR SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND THE
GREATER URBAN AREAS OF OUR
STATE. IT HARVEY MILK WAS WITH
US TODAY. I FEEL HE WOULD BE
LEADING EQUALITY MARCHES IN
RURAL AREAS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
LGBT PEOPLE EVERYWHERE. KNEW
THAT BIGHTER DAYS ARE ON THE
HORIZON AND THAT HOPE. IS STILL
ALIVE. EVERY LGBT CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD KNOW AND FEEL COMFORT
HERE IN OUR STATE. THAT THEY
ARE EQUAL IN ALL WAYS. AND THEY
CAN LOVE ANYONE THEY WANT A LOT
OF. HARVEY MILK GAVE HIS LIFE
IN PURSUIT OF EQUALITY. FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIA HIS DREAM IS
OUR DREAM IT IS THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM. IT IS A GREAT HONOR FOR
ME TO BE ABLE TO SALUTE HARVEY
MILK A TRUE ICON OF CIVIL
RIGHTS EVERYWHERE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISTER
MORGAN MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE REFLECTION
IN SUPPORT FROM COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE STATE I WOULD ASK
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS AND APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. WITHOUT THE
CLERICAL OF THE ROLE FOR COAL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE
ARE FIFTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING BACK ONE ITEM IN
THE FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OH SEVEN ONE OH SEVEN
H. BAR FORTY ONE BY MR MAYES.
CORPORATE HOUSE WAS LUCIEN
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAYES AND OTHER PHILOSOPHY
HUMAN RIGHTS OF WORKERS. MR
MAYS EMAIL BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO BRING FOR H. R. FORTY
ONE TO STRONGLY DENOUNCED THE
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS
COMMITTED AGAINST THE WEAKER
PEOPLE. SOME OF YOU MIGHT BE
ASKING WHY BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FOR TODAY TO THAT OF
A SIMPLE ANSWER. LIKE MANY
AMERICANS I HEARD ABOUT THE
POOR TREATMENT OF UIGHURS IN
THE XINJIANG REGION OF CHINA.
THE HOME OF UIGHURS CALL EAST
TURKISTAN BUT DO NOT UNDERSTAND
THE HUMAN IMPACT AT THE TIME.
HOWEVER TWO YEARS AGO I MET AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO STORY BROUGHT
THE WEAKER STRUGGLE FROM THE
NEWS. INTO MY LIFE. MEMBERS THE
NIGHTMARE WEAKER AMERICANS
FACES WHEN YOU CANNOT WAKE UP
FROM. CUT OFF FROM THEIR
FAMILIES BACK HOME RELATIVES
AND NEIGHBOURS VANISHED INTO
THE DARKNESS OF CHINESE
GOVERNMENT RUN REGGIE CATION
CAMPS. INTERNATIONAL REPORTS
CONFIRM THE HORROR WITH
DOCUMENTED CASES OF TORTURE
SANCTIONED RAPE FAMILY
SEPARATION ORGAN HARVESTING
CULTURE REVOCATION AND DEATH.
THE TREATMENT OF THESE TWO
MILLION UIGHURS IS A STAIN ON
THE WHOLE OF HUMANITY THAT WE
MUST NOT BE SILENT ABOUT.
ANSWERS FROM THE GOVERNMENT ARE
SHROUDED IN LIES AND DECEIT
WITH THE ONLY TRUTH BEING
SMUGGLED OUT SHAKY CELLPHONE
VIDEOS OF THE SPORADIC TEXT.
BUT EVEN THESE GLIMMERS OF
TRUTH BRING MANY FAMILIES
DREAD. AS THE REALIZATION OF
WHAT THEIR LOVED ONES ARE
LIVING THROUGH MANIFESTS. THIS
IS NOT TO SAY THAT OUR STATE
NATION HAS NO DEMONS TO GRAPPLE
WITH OURSELVES THE WRONGS WE
HAVE COMMITTED IN THE PAST
CANNOT PREVENT US FROM TAKING
ACTION AS RUNS APPEAR BEFORE
OUR VERY EYES. HUMANITY IS
UNIQUE IN OUR CONTRADICTION WE
EXHIBIT GREAT KINDNESS BUT CAN
BE MERCILESS TO THOSE WE HATE.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO RAPIDLY
BUILD A BETTER WORLD. BUT CAN
DESTROY IT IN SECONDS. MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO GROW FROM OUR PREDECESSORS
MISTAKES IT IS THAT GROWTH IN
THIS YEAR DEMANDING THE RELEASE
OF TWO MILLION HUMANS BEING
HELD AGAINST THEIR WILL. IN
DOING SO YOU MUST NOT ATTEMPT
TO RIDE OUR MORAL HIGH HORSE
OVER OTHER NATIONS BUT INSTEAD.
SHOW THEM THE SCARS FROM OUR
OWN FAILINGS IN HOPES THEY
MIGHT EMERGE UNBLEMISHED. IT IS
ONLY THEN WE CAN HOPE TO WAKE
UP FROM THE NIGHTMARE OCCURRING
TO THE WEAKER PEOPLE. MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND ASKED THE RULE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MISTER MESS. MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION A
MISSILE OF A MICHELIN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR DESK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS ESOLUTION
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS. AND AS A
MEMBER OF ALL HUMANITY WHO
AFTER ALL SPEAKS TODAY OF THE
ANNIHILATION OF THE ARMENIANS.
MEMBERS THESE WORDS WERE A
DRAFT OF THE SPEECH ADOLF
HITLER DELIVERED TO HIS
OFFICERS ON THE EVE OF THE ****
INVASION OF POLAND IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE. WE DIDN'T NEED TO
WAIT FOR THIS SPEECH TO
UNDERSTAND THE GENOCIDAL MANIA
AT THE HEART OF IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE THE NUREMBERG RACE
LAWS. STRIPPED GERMAN JEWS OF
THEIR CITIZENSHIP POGROMS WERE
ORGANIZED MASSACRES IN RIOTS
AIMED AT ETHNIC CLEANSING
AGAINST JEWS WERE COMMONPLACE
IN EUROPE AT THE TURN OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WHAT MOTIVATED MY
OWN ANCESTORS TO FLEE TO
AMERICA. AND IN NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT KRISTALLNACHT THE NIGHT
OF BROKEN GLASS WAS A ****
PARTY SPONSORED PROGRAM THAT
DESTROYED THE HOMES BUSINESSES
SYNAGOGUES AND SCHOOLS OF
JEWISH GERMANS. THAT NIGHT.
**** ARRESTED THIRTY THOUSAND
JEWS AND SENT THEM TO GHETTOS
WHERE THEY WERE SLOWLY MURDERED
THREE STARVATION. BEFORE THEIR
LIVES WHOEVER SURVIVED THE
GHETTOS BEFORE THOSE LIVES WERE
EVENTUALLY LIQUIDATED IN GAS
CHAMBERS AND THEIR BODIES
BURNED IN OVENS IN THE
HOLOCAUST THAT FORMALLY BOOK
BEGAN IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE AND
TOOK ELEVEN MILLION INNOCENT
LIVES. ULTIMATELY WE LEARNED
THAT NO ONE WAS WILLING TO SAVE
JEWISH LIVES THEY LOOK
DIFFERENT THEY SPOKE A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE THEY PRAYED
DIFFERENTLY LET'S FACE IT IN
THE FACE OF ANNIHILATION OR
ATTACKS. NO ONE STICKS UP FOR
JEWS AND TOO FREQUENTLY ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS OTHER LIKE READERS.
IT'S GRUESOME. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
WORLD HISTORY OF INACTION. IT'S
IMPORTANT NO OF THE WORLD'S
HISTORY OF INACTION EVEN WHEN
IT KNOWS OF THREATS TO
MINORITIES. AND WE KNEW IN
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE BETWEEN
THE NUREMBERG RACE LAWS IN THE
HOLOCAUST WE GET BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE GERMANY
HOSTED THE OLYMPICS IN NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX HITLER. SAW THE
GAMES AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROMOTE HIS GOVERNMENT AND
IDEALS OF RACIAL SUPREMACY AND
ANTI SEMITISM AND THE OFFICIAL
**** PARTY PAPER WROTE THAT
JEWS SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GAMES.
JEWISH ATHLETES FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE SAID TO HAVE BEEN
SIDELINED JUST TO AVOID
OFFENDING THE **** REGIME. NO
MEMBERS THIS ISN'T HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY I AM RISING TO
SPEAK OUT FOR THE RIGHTS OF
UIGHURS IN XINJIANG IT'S IN FAR
EASTERN CHINA IF YOU NEED HELP
FINDING IT. ON A MAP THEIR
MUSLIM. AND AGAIN THEY'RE
REALLY FAR AWAY FROM ANYTHING-
BUT WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT CHINA'S
PERSECUTION OF UIGHURS FOR
YEARS. WE HAVE SATELLITE
IMAGERY. DOCUMENTING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF CONCENTRATION
CAMPS BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IT NOW MILLIONS OF WOMEN AND
MEN ARE INCARCERATED IN SLAVE
CAMPS. AS I SHARED WITH YOU
LAST WEEK WOMEN HAVE BEEN
FORCIBLY STERILIZED TWO
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATIONS
HAVE HAD SECRETARIES OF STATE
WARREN OF GENOCIDE. THERE IS A
GLOBAL DEMAND FOR BLACK HAIR
AND TONS OF IT HAD BEEN
DETAINED BY CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL SUSPECTED OF COMING FROM
WEAKER HEADS ARRIVING IN
AMERICA IN THE FORM. OF WEAVES
AND WIGS. THIRTEEN TONS JUST
LAST JULY. IF YOU HAVE EVER
THOUGHT IF YOU AGREE THAT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE HUMAN RIGHTS
PLEASE DON'T LET THAT JUST BE A
SLOGAN. THIS IS YOUR BECAUSE
RIGHT HERE. IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS ARE HUMAN
RIGHTS DON'T LET THAT JUST BE A
TWEET THIS IS YOUR FIGHT RIGHT
HERE FOR UIGHUR WOMEN AND MEN.
MAKE YOUR VOTE COUNT FOR
SOMETHING. I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION BUT WE MUST DO
MORE. THE LEAST WE CAN DO IS
NOTHING. THIS RESOLUTION IS THE
EASIEST THING THAT WE CAN DO
THE EASIEST. IT WASHES AWAY OUR
GUILT OVER INACTION. WE MUST DO
MORE WE CAN'T JUST LET THIS
CONTINUE. AND GUESS WHO'S
HOSTING THE WINTER OLYMPICS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO THIRTY SECONDS
CHINA. EVERY VOTE YOU TAKE
MEMBERS EVERY VOTE EVERY TIME
YOU CONSIDER AN ISSUE THAT
INVOLVES CHINA PLEASE MAKE YOUR
VOTE MEAN SOMETHING PLEASE MAKE
YOUR VOTE COUNT FOR SOMETHING
LET'S NOT BE CONDEMNED TO
REPEAT THE PAST. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE. MISTER NAZARIAN. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES FIRST
OF ALL I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
FORTY ONE AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM SPRINGS FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE- COUPLE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN VERY
ELOQUENTLY DETAILING. SOME OF
THE ATROCITIES THAT WE ARE
FINDING OUT ABOUT. COLLEAGUES
BY THE TIME WE ACTUALLY KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON IT'S
TOO LATE. TOO MANY LIVES WOULD
HAVE BEEN LOST. WE KNOW THIS
THROUGH HISTORY. WE KNOW THAT
WHEN WE UNRAVEL THINGS AFTER
YEARS OF HAPPENING. IT'S
ALREADY TOO LATE. AND POLITICS
WHEN POLITICS GETS INVOLVED AND
MAKES A FORCEFUL DECISION. IT'S
ALREADY WAY TOO LATE. SO IF
THERE'S ANY HOPE OF MAKING A
DIFFERENCE NOW IS THE TIME FOR
US TO BE THAT BEACON OF LIGHT
THAT STARTS MAKING AN IMPACT
FOR THE REST OF THE WORLD. I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
OF THINGS TO YOU. A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO WHEN THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE WAS BEING PERPETRATED.
AND SYSTEMICALLY BEING
CONDUCTED. THE REST OF THE
WORLD WAS NOT GOING TO KNOW IF
IT WASN'T FOR THE ACT OF A
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE. ONE WAS THE
US AMBASSADOR. HENRY MORGENTHAU.
WHO ON A DAILY BASIS WROTE
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING. AND
WAS NOTIFYING THE REST OF THE
WORLD. IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
CHRONOLOGY OF THE DOCUMENTATION
THAT HE PROVIDED MOST OF THESE
EVENTS COULD HAVE BEEN LOST OR
JUST BEEN HERE SAY. BUT THERE
ARE STATE DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTS
OF WHAT HAPPENED. SECOND WAS
THE GERMAN OFFICER BY THE NAME
OF ARMIN WAGNER. GERMANS WERE
COLLABORATE TURKEY WAS
COLLABORATING WITH GERMANY AND
FOR IN THE FIRST WORLD WAR
GERMANS OFFICERS WERE SENT TO
ACTUALLY HELP. WITH THE
PERSECUTION AND THE GENOCIDE OF
ARMENIANS. BUT SOME OF THEM HAD
A CONSCIENCE AND AS THEY WERE
WATCHING WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
ARMIN WAGNER IF YOU CAN IMAGINE
AT THAT TIME IN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN HAD A CAMERA AND WAS
DOCUMENTING EVERYTHING ONE BY
ONE MOST OF THE PHOTOS THAT
SURVIVE TILL TODAY ARE
THANKFULLY HIS. THESE ARE JUST
TWO NAMES OF PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY HELPED CHRONICLE
SOMETHING SO ATROCIOUS THAT WAS
HAPPENING. CURRENT DAY. WE HAVE
MULTIPLE WAYS OF NEW SENIOR AND
KNOWING IT. AND THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE THAT HASN'T BEEN COMING
OUT GOD ONLY KNOWS WHEN IT WILL.
SO KNOWING WHERE WE ARE AT
KNOWING WHAT WE'RE CAPABLE OF
UNFORTUNATELY KNOWING WHAT
WE'RE CAPABLE OF DOING
SOMETIMES EVEN AS HUMANITY I
ASKED THAT WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND STRONG DISSECTS IT
SENT A STRONG SIGNAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN MR
GABRIEL YOUR RECOGNIZE AT YOUR
DESK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
FORTY ONE I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM YUCCA VALLEY FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR THIS. SO
OFTEN HE DOES LEADING WITH HIS
VALUES AND BEING A MORAL VOICE.
FOR OUR BODY I DON'T HAVE MUCH
TO ADD TO THE REALLY ELOQUENT
AND POWERFUL WORDS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. BUT IFELT THAT I
COULDN'T REMAIN SILENT AND THAT
I NEEDED TO STAND UP AND SPEAK
OUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. WE HAVE SPENT TIME
ON THIS FLOOR A LOT OF TIME
RECENTLY TALKING ABOUT GENOCIDE
THAT WERE COMMITTED IN THE
PAST. TALKING ABOUT THE NEED
TO. COMMEMORATE AND UNDERSTAND
THOSE GENOCIDES THE NEED TO
TEACH ABOUT THEM TO BUILD
MEMORIALS TO THEM. BUT PART OF
THAT PURPOSE IS TO PREVENT
GENOCIDE FROM HAPPENING AGAIN
TO ANYONE WHETHER THAT IS
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY OR AN
ETHNIC MUSLIM MINORITY IN CHINA
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
AGAIN WE HAVE AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
SAID TO. TWO TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL PARTIES THAT HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THERE IS A
GENOCIDE TAKING PLACE. I READ
AN ARTICLE RECENTLY IN THE BBC
ABOUT THE SYSTEMATIC FORCED
RAPE OF UIGHUR WOMEN IN CUSTODY
IT IS AMONG THE MOST DIFFICULT
THINGS THAT I HAVE EVER READ IN
MY LIFE. SO I WANT TO COMMEND
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM YUCCA VALLEY
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE THAT WE SET TODAY. BUT
I AGREE THAT IT MUST BE ONLY
THE FIRST STEP THAT WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO RAISE
THIS ISSUE TO BRING THE ISSUE
OF FOR OF GENOCIDE AGAINST
UIGHURS TO THE FOREFRONT. I
STAND STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND I THINK ARE CALLING
FOR HELPING US TO FOCUS ON THIS
DIFFICULT. AND COMPLICATED BUT
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION. MISTER MAYES YOU
MAY CLOSE A MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO THANK.
MY COLLEAGUES- FOR LENDING AND
THEIR- THEIR VOICE AND SUCH A
ARTICULATE ELOQUENT WAY THIS IS
A STAIN ON ALL OF HUMANITY OUR
VOICES MUST BE HEARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND- MISTER SPEAKER IF THE
FIRST REAL CAN BE OPENED- FOR
CO AUTHORS. WITH TECHNICAL OF
THE ROLE. IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION HOW AUTHORS ON
HR. FORTY ONE. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
WELL CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY ONE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON HOW FOR ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE HIS IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
WILLIAM TO TAKE UP ITEM A AB
TEN NINETY BY MISTER THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BOLTON
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO IMMIGRATION.
MYSTERY TAT CHAU. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT AB TEN NINETY SIX A
LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY. AB TEN
NINETY SIX DELETES THE OUTDATED
AND OFFENSIVE TERM ALIEN WHICH
IS FOUND THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
LAWS AND REPLACES IT WITH
APPROPRIATE LEGAL TERMINOLOGY
SUCH AS NON CITIZEN. ALTHOUGH
THE TERM ALIEN HAS HISTORICALLY
REFERRED TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE NON CITIZENS. THE WORD WAS
SINCE HAS SINCE BEEN WEAPONIZED
AND USED IN PLACE OF AN
EXPLICITLY RACIAL SLUR. THERE
IS A DIRECT LINK BETWEEN WORDS
AND ACTIONS AND HISTORY HAS
PROVEN THAT DEHUMANIZING
LANGUAGE OFTEN PRECEDES VILE
ACTIONS WE HAVE ALL WITNESSED
THE HORRIFIC INCREASE IN
CRIMES. IN THIS YEAR ALONE
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED HATE CRIMES
TOWARDS OUR API COMMUNITY AND
OTHER VIOLENT ATTACKS TOWARD
OTHER COMMUNITIES. EVIDENCE
THAT OUR COUNTRY CONTINUES TO
REEL FROM RACIST VIOLENCE. AB
TEN NINETY SIX INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS ARE CAN
CONSISTENT OF TERMINOLOGY. THAT
ALIGNS WITH OUR IDEALS THANK
YOU. THANK IS RIVAS MAYES RUBIO
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE K. LET. MUCH **** IN
SUPPORT OF A- TEN NINETY SAY
WHICH IS AN OFFICIAL PARTY BY
FOR. THIS LED TO WILL REMOVE D.
HIM DE. TERM ILLEGAL FOR STATE.
LANGUAGE AND RHETORIC MATTERS.
THE WAY WE TALK ABOUT- DESCRIBE
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
REFLECTS OUR STATE'S VALUES.
ESPECIALLY IN THE PAST YEAR
WE'VE SEEN HOW HATEFUL PHRASES
CAN LEAD TO HATEFUL ACTIONS AND
VIOLENCE. THE TERM ILLEGAL
ALIEN HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
USED TO DISCRIMINATE AND
DENIGRATE ARE UNDOCUMENTED
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY. APART
FROM BRINGING COUNTLESS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS ARE OUR
NEIGHBORS TEACHERS DOCTORS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND YES EVEN
A CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND A CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATOR. IN OUR STATE WE AIM TO
UP LEFT AND EMBRACE OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THE TERM ILLEGAL
ALIEN BELONGS NOWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE FOR AB TEN NINETY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR RUBIO
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR AND IS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN NINETY
SIX. WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
AND NEIGHBOR FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. AND
KNOW THAT THE JEWISH CAUCUS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO ENDORSE
THIS MEASURE WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT. IN SUPPORT OF AN
OFFER TO SIMPLE OBSERVATIONS.
ONE LIKE ARE CALLING FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY MENTIONED
WORDS MATTER. WORDS ARE
POWERFUL INSTRUMENTS. THEY CAN
DEEPLY INFLUENCE OUR BEHAVIOR
AND THE WAY THAT WE TREAT EACH
OTHER. AND THERE HAS BEEN SO
MUCH HATEFUL AND DEHUMANIZING
RHETORIC DIRECTED TOWARDS OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN RECENT
YEARS. IT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
THOUGHTFUL AND INTENTIONAL AND
INCLUSIVE IN THE WAY THAT WE-
WRITE OUR LAWS. AND SECOND WHEN
WE SPEAK ABOUT ARE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
NEIGHBORS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VITAL MEMBERS OF OUR FAMILIES.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE
SPECIAL PLACE THAT IT IS TODAY.
WITHOUT THE EXTRAORDINARY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS. AND SO IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT OUR STATE LAW
REFLECT THIS REALITY. AND THAT
WE DESCRIBE AND TREAT
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WITH
THE RESPECT AND THE DIGNITY
THAT THEY DESERVE. SO I GOT A
PLOT ARE CALLING FOR BRING YOU
FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. AND
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON AB
TEN NINETY SIX. TEKNISKA MR
LOW. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER IN
COLLEGE I THINK THE MEMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES FROM BRING THIS
FORWARD. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS VICE
CHAIR. IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
THERE WAS THE CALIFORNIA ALIEN
LAND LAW WHICH FOR A BIT ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS FROM OWNING
PROPERTY IN OUR STATE. THIS IS
A RECOGNITION ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO
REFLECT ON OUR DARK HISTORY AND
CORRECT THE WRONGS OF THE PAST
COLLECTIVELY AS ONE BODY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. IN
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH ALL
COMMUNITIES. THANKS FOR THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MISTER SEAKER
I RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. THE WORDS
WEUSE MATTER THEY TELL US WHO
WE ARE AND WHAT WE VALUE. I
TELL YOU PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR WHO
THEY ARE NOT WHERE THEY CAME
FROM. FOR TOO LONG THE WORD
ALIEN HAS BEEN USED TO SLANDER
IMMIGRANT TO COMMUNITIES AND
DENY OUR HUMANITY THOSE OF US
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY KNOW
THAT WHEN PEOPLE REFER TO
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AS
ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE ALIENS
THEY'RE DOING SO NOT BECAUSE OF
A LEGAL PREFERENCE BUT TO TELL
US THAT WE DO NOT BELONG. AND
THAT WE ARE NOT WANTED. IT IS
PAST TIME WE FINALLY REMOVE
THIS TERM FROM OUR LEXICON AND
OUR LAWS. THIS IS A LATINO
CAUCUS PRIORITY AS MENTIONED BY
MY COLLEAGUE. AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THEY ADDRESS MR JONES SAWYER WE
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LISTED BLACK MARKET.
WE JOIN OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FROM THE LATINO CAUCUS
IN SOLIDARITY. ON THIS
PROPOSAL. WE MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE KNOW WHAT LABELS CAN DO. I
PERSONALLY LED. THE EFFORT TO
REMOVE AT RISK AT PROMISED
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT A WORD CAN
DO TO NOT ONLY GET PEOPLE. BUT
TO A PERSON AND STIGMATIZE
IMMINENT SYSTEM ADVERSE WAY.
THAT IT STIGMATIZES THE BILL
THE ENTIRE RACE THE ENTIRE
PEOPLE AND EVEN INDIVIDUALS SO
THEY CAN PROGRESS TO BECOME
THEY'RE THE BEST THAT THEY CAN
BE. WE NEED TO REMOVE THESE
LABELS. WE NEED TO REMOVE ALL
OF THESE LABELS WHICH FURTHER
KEEPS A GROUP OF PEOPLE DOWN.
AND SO I JOIN WITH MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS THAT WE'D HALF WE
HAVE TO EVERY TIME WE SEE
SOMETHING. WE SAY SOMETHING WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE EQUALIZE TO
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR DECADES
AND DECADES AND DECADES.
ABUSING LANGUAGE AS OPPRESSORS
OF THE PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE BILL THIS
RIVAS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES AND REPRESENTATIVES
FROM OUR CAUCUSES THAT SET UP
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL- OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ALSO SHARED WITH
ME HOW PERSONAL THIS IS TO THEM
IN THEIR IVES- AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK. MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THAT CORRECTED PART
OF MY OPENING STATEMENT I
MENTIONED THERE HAD BEEN THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED HATE CRIMES
TOWARD THE AAPI COMMUNITY AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HAS RISEN
AND WE ARE NOW AT SIXTY SIX
HUNDRED- WHICH I THINK. OF IT
REVEALS WHY THIS BILL IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT WE NEED TO GET
RID OF HATE IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. NAME IS RIVAS
AND WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE. FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE SEVEN EIGHT OPERATOR
ASSEMBLY GROW NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AN ACTOR
LIVING TO MOBILE HOMES MS CLARK
SILVA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB NINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT IS A
VERY NARROW DISTRICT RENT
STABILIZATION BILL FOR A MOBILE
HOME PARK IN MY DISTRICT. THAT
SITS ONLY NOT ONLY IN FULLERTON
BUT ANAHEIM RANTULA PLUS MOBILE
HOME PARK. AS WE KNOW IN THE
LAST DECADE RENTS HAVE
INCREASED SKYROCKETING
SKYROCKETED AND MANY PEOPLE
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO STAY IN
THEIR APARTMENTS BUT THIS ISSUE
IS ABOUT A MOBILE HOME PARK. A
NEW OWNER BROUGHT THIS PARK AND-
SADLY HAS INCREASED THE RENTS
UP 220% FOR SOME AND NOW EVEN
CLOSE 240% THESE PARK RENTERS
ARE SENIORS VETERANS. THESE
PEOPLE HAVE WORKED HARD THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE AND MANY OF THEM
BOUGHT THIS MOBILE HOME. AS
THEIR FOREVER HOME THEY'RE ON
FIXED INCOMES. AND THERE RENTS
HAVE INCREASED FROM SOME THAT
WERE CLOSE TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO NOW ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS SIMPLY
MEANS THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT
THEY'RE ON FIXED INCOMES. AND
TALKING TO THESE CONSTITUENTS
OF MINE THEY HAVE SAID THAT
SOME OF THEM ARE NOT ONLY
GETTING SICK BECAUSE OF THE
STRESS. THEY'VE ENTERED POVEDA
AND NOW THEY'RE EVEN LINED UP
FOR FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS AND-
PUTTING THEIR MEDICATIONS ON
HOLD BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN MEDICATION. OR
RENT. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED FROM A STATE WIDE.
MOBILE HOME RENT STABILIZATION
BILL TO THIS PARTICULAR PARK.
AS WE KNOW WE ARE SEEING MANY
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HOMES APARTMENTS AND EVEN
MOBILE HOMES AND THIS BILL
WOULD DO THE LEAST WHICH IS TO
HELP KEEP THESE PEOPLE HOUSE.
THE VITAL BILL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISS
CORK SILVA MISTER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRAIN IS REALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE MOBILE HOME PARKS
REPRESENT SOME OF THE BEST A
NATURALLY OCCURRING. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. HOMES FOR A LOT OF OUR
VILMORIN SENIORS. AND THIS BILL
WITH ITS NARROW PROVISIONS IS
ABLE TO PROTECT A LOT MORE
RANGERS WE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
CONFRONTING A HOUSING CRISIS.
WHILE ALSO PREVENTING MORE
FOLKS ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS BRING BECOMING HOMELESS
SO- JR I VOTE ON THIS. THANK
YOU MISTER LAKE I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE RECOGNITION THIS
COURSE OF YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE.
CATEGORIZE FORTY SEVEN OF
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER. FILE IN FORTY AB SIX
FIFTY TWO BY MISS FRIEDMAN
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY TWO BY SUMMER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE
PRODUCT SAFETY THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS- MEMBERS AS A MOM I CAN
TELL YOU THAT NOTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO ME THAN THE HEALTH
OF MY DAUGHTER AND I KNOW THAT
MANY OF YOUR PARENTS. AND WANT
TO DO YOUR BEST TO PROTECT YOUR
CHILDREN NOW WE PUT A LOT OF
MONEY AND EFFORT IN THIS
COUNTRY TO DEALING WITH. THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF CANCER- MONEY
TO PREVENTION MONEY TO
TREATMENT MONEY TO RESEARCH BUT
ONE PLACE- WE'VE LACKED IS
PREVENTION ACTUAL PREVENTION.
TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT THE
CHEMICALS THAT WE KNOW. OUR
DIRECT CONTRIBUTORS TO CANCER.
WE HAVE BECOME AWARE IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT A CLASS
OF CHEMICALS BEING P. FALSE IS
HURLEY CARCINOGENIC. NOW AS A
MOM IN CALIFORNIA WHEN I BUY A
PRODUCT ON THE SHELF HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS PRETTY
INNOCUOUS LIKE A MATTRESS. OR
TOY I MAKE THE ASSUMPTION IS A
MOM THAT THAT TOY IS SAFE FOR
MY CHILD BECAUSE I AM BUYING IT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE I
ASSUME WE HAVE HIGH STANDARDS
FOR SAFETY. BUT WE NOW KNOW
THAT WE HAVE ALLOWED FOR MANY
YEARS THIS CARCINOGENIC CLASS
OF CHEMICALS BEING FEE FOSS. TO
BE USED ON. THE ON THE HUMAN
BEINGS WHOSE BODIES ARE AT THE
MOMENT OF DEVELOPMENT WHEN THEY
ARE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO
CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS. NOW WE
HAVEN'T DONE THIS BECAUSE THESE
CHEMICALS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THESE PRODUCTS. WE'RE NOT EVEN
TALKING NECESSARILY ABOUT
ESSENTIAL PRODUCTS FOR THE
CHEMICAL CERTAINLY ARE NOT
ESSENTIAL TO MATTRESSES TO
TOYS. TO TEDDY BEARS AND YET
THEY ARE ROUTINELY USED ON
THOSE PRODUCTS. EVEN THOUGH
THOSE CHEMICALS ARE BANNED
OUTRIGHT IN MANY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD BECAUSE OF
THEIR CARCINOGENIC MATERIAL.
MEMBERS IT IS TIME THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA SAY. THAT WE PUT THE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN.
PARAMOUNT TO ANY OTHER CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE. AND FORBID THE
USE OF P. FOSS ON JUVENILE
PRODUCTS A MEMBERS THE INDUSTRY.
THAT MANUFACTURES THESE
PRODUCTS IN THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY BROUGHT US CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS AT THE LAST HEARING
HAVING TO DO WITH A FEW CLASS
OF PRODUCTS THAT THEY FELT
ACTUALLY NEED THESE CHEMICALS
BEING ELECTRONICS. AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES WE HAPPILY AMENDED THE
BILL TO EXCLUDE THOSE PRODUCTS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ANY REMAINING CONCERNS.
BUT I THINK THAT WE OWE IT TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THAT THEY NEVER HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAVE OF
WONDERING ABOUT INADVERTENTLY
HURT MY CHILD JUST BECAUSE I
BOUGHT THE PRODUCT THAT I HAD
NO IDEA WAS SPRAYED WITH
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW CAUSES
CANCER MEMBERS AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE ON A. B. SIX FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CORPORAL.
SACRAMENTO MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
RESERVIST. WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF THAT I SHOULD ONE NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL
FIRST TAKE UP THE RESOLUTIONS.
THAT ARE ON CONSENT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL READ. THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL RELATIVE
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS WE-
CARBONELL THE ROLLOUT. THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS IS A
VOTE FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION ON CONSENT. THIS IS
THAT YOUR NAME IS A CO AUTHOR
ON THAT RESOLUTION ON CONSENT.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED. THERE
IS FOR MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF THE
CITY MEMBERS TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE BY SOME MEMBERS SAY
ARTS- AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO CLEAR
THE AIR SEEDER OF CYCLIC
MEDIALLY. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ON NUMBERS FOR WHICH TO
VOTE THIS IS THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR. MEMBERS THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WHO WISH TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ON THE URGENCY. I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITSELF. SEVENTY TWO
ZERO. THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY THREE I. SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH NINE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO FOR SOME PEOPLE
THREE TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SOME PEOPLE THREE
TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY TWO DOUBLE
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
FOUR I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY GO IT'LL THREE-
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SUM. EACH
SEVENTY THREE FIVE SEVEN IF YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME LEGAL EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE I. SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE NINE THIRTEEN
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SUM OF-
NINE SIXTY TWO FIVE SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO SUM OF- NINE NINETY TWO
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TEND TO. I. SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO SUM WE GO TO NINETY
FIVE I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SUM
OF ELEVEN FORTY FOUR I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SUM OF ELEVEN FORTY
NINE I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SUM
OF ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SOME PEOPLE LIVE
IN SEVENTY THREE. SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO SUM WE WILL. TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO
ZERO. SOME PEOPLE TOLD SIXTY
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN EIGHT KNOWS
SUM THIRTEEN. NINE I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS. SOME PEOPLE FOR
FIFTY. I SAID TWO ZERO PEOPLE
FOR. SEVEN FOUR I SEVEN TWO
KNOWS. SUM FORTY FIFTY TWO.
FIVE SEVENTY TWO NOW ZERO SO
PEOPLE FOR. EIGHTY I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SOME AGO FIFTEEN
ELEVEN I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ASSUMING CURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BEFORE ANYONE. I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO INCIDENT
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FOR.
FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT ZERO ZERO. MEMBERS
WELL WE ARE I DON'T FOR ONE
MOMENT. I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WE'LL BE MEETING
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER GERMAN OF
SESSION. THAT'S FIFTEEN MINUTES
AFTER THE GERMAN OF SESSION. IN
THE MEETING WILL OCCUR HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. SESSION
SCHEDULED FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
FIRST NO FOR SESSION A CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY TWENTY
FOURTH THE FOUR SESSION IS A
ONE. GM.
MEMBERS WE ARE GIVING
QUORUM CALL IN PLACE. WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS QUORUM CALL IS IN
PLACE PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES WEIRD
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
HER PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY MISTER SEA ARE
TELL. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF JORDAN ERIN KRANZ
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
CANYON LAKE. JORDAN SERVED ON
THE CANYON LAKE CITY COUNCIL
FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS INCLUDING
THREE TERMS OF MAY AS MAYOR HE
REPRESENTED THE CITY ON
NUMEROUS REGIONAL BOARDS
INCLUDING THE WESTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS THE REST
WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
COUNTY REGIONAL CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY AND THE NORTH WEST.
MISKITO VECTOR CONTROL DISTRICT
AND THE ECONOMIC AND ENERGY A
COMMITTEE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. WHERE DID THAT HE
HAD SERVED ON THE BOARD OF THE
CANYON LAKE PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION FOR FIVE YEARS AND
WAS BOARD PRESIDENT THREE YEARS.
JORDAN WAS A PROPERTY OWNER IN
CANYON LAKE FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS AND A FULL TIME RESIDENT
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE. HE
WAS WELL KNOWN LOVED AND AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN JORDAN
WAS NAMED THE CANYON LAKE
CITIZEN OF THE YEAR. HIS
LEADERSHIP DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND LOVE FOR THE
COMMUNITY WERE UNMATCHED AND HE
HAS LEFT A LASTING LEGACY IN
THE CITY OF CANYON LAKE.
COUNCILMEMBER AARON GROUNDS
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVELY WIFE
FIVE CHILDREN AND SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN. MEMBERS I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND AGAIN I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF CANYON LAKE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER JORDAN EHRENKRANTZ.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR SAY OUR
TELL MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS. TODAY WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DMITRI
BELSER. A PILLAR OF BERKELEY'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS COMMUNITY
DIMITRI'S ADVOCACY AND LIFETIME
OF SERVICE HAS TOUCHED
COUNTLESS LIVES AND HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED WELL BEYOND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTEEN. TWO MAJOR IS
BEST KNOWN FOR HIS PAROLE AND
GETTING THE ED ROBERTS CAMPUS
BUILT IN THE HEART OF BERKELEY.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
ESTABLISHING THE TRANSIT
ORIENTED CAMPUS AT THE ASHBY
BART STATION WHICH IS DEDICATED
TO IMPROVING SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. DIMITRI DID
REMARKABLE WORK. AND THE REST
OF HIS LIFE WAS NO DIFFERENT.
HE WAS BORN IN BOSTON IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND
ATTENDED HAMPSHIRE COLLEGE.
GRADUATING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. IT WAS THERE THAT HE MET
FELLOW STUDENT TOM WHITE WHO AT
THE TIME IT WAS QUOTE SLINGING
HASH AT A TACO JOINT. DIMITRI
INTRODUCED HIMSELF BY. KISSING
TOM OVER THE LUNCH COUNTER IN
HIS TYPICAL FORD AWA OF QUOTE
GETTING THINGS DONE. DIMITRI
TOLD TOM HE WAS FIXING UP IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE SIXTY
THREE VOLKSWAGEN VAN WHICH YOU
PLAN TO DRIVE TO CALIFORNIA
THAT SUMMER AND ASKED IF TOM
WOULD LIKE TO COME. THE COUPLE
MADE THEIR WAY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO SAN FRANCISCO AND
EVENTUALLY BOUGHT IN NINETEEN
TWELVE ROW HOUSE IN BERNAL
HEIGHTS. THE COUPLE BEGAN GOING
TO ADOPTION AGENCIES AND A
DESIRE TO GROW THEIR FAMILY.
THEY WERE TOLD QUOTE THERE WERE
CERTAIN MORAL REQUIREMENTS.
THAT COULD NOT BE OVERLOOKED. A
VAGUELY CODED MESSAGE THAT SAME
SEX COUPLES WERE NOT CONSIDERED
ELIGIBLE TO RAISE FAMILIES. BUT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE A
MUTUAL FRIEND BROUGHT TO ME
TRAIN TOM TOGETHER WITH THE
BIRTH MOTHER OF A BEAUTIFUL
BABY GIRL NAMED THALIA AND THEY
KNEW INSTANTLY IS THAT SHE WAS
THEIR DAUGHTER. THE COUPLE
WELCOME TELLING INTO THEIR
FAMILY AND AN OPEN ADOPTION
EVER MADE FRIENDS WITH HER
BIRTH MOTHER. THEY MOVED TO
SOUTH BERKELEY NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AND ADOPTED A FIVE MONTH
OLD SEBASTIAN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE ALSO THROUGH AN
OPEN ADOPTION. THE COUPLE WERE
WHAT IT THREE TIMES. A CIVIL
UNION IN VERMONT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. A WEDDING IN
VANCOUVER CANADA IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE. AND AGAIN AT
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY COURTHOUSE
IN OAKLAND FINALLY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. OVER THE
LAST FEW DECADES DIMITRI AND
TERMINATED TEN HISTORIC HOMES
THAT WERE OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OLD AND RESCUED SEVERAL
HISTORIC PROPERTIES FROM
DESTRUCTION. DIMITRI WAS
LEGALLY BLIND AND ONCE SERVED
AS A SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY HE LATER BECAME THE
COORDINATOR OF DEAF STUDENT
SERVICES FOR THE UNIVERSE
ADVERSITIES DEFINITE SABLE
SERVICE CENTER. AND THEN ASSUME
A MANAGER AT PACIFIC BELL
STEPHAN DISABLE SERVICE CENTER.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND ONE HE
BECAME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER FOR ACCESSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY A BERKELEY BASED
NONPROFIT THAT INTEREST PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES CAN ACCESS A
SAID ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY. TO
BE AS INDEPENDENT AS POSSIBLE.
AFTER HIS TIRELESS WORK TO GET
THE ED ROBERTS CAMPUS BUILT
DIMITRI SERVED AS ITS PRESIDENT
TWICE HIS CHARISMA AND ABILITY
TO BRING GROUPS OF DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER WERE
CRITICAL TO THE CENTER SUCCESS.
INTO HIS UNDERLYING COMMITMENT
IS TO SERVICE AN EQUAL RIGHTS.
DIMITRI WAS SIXTY SEVEN WHEN HE
PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND THREE MONTHS AFTER BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS HUSBAND TOM
WHITE DAUGHTER THALIA AND SON
SEBASTIAN MOTHER CHARLOTTE
BALSER SISTER STEPHANIE AND
BELSER BROTHER MARC BILL SIR.
AND BY THREE NEPHEWS AND ONE
NIECE. DEMETER UNDERSTOOD THE
URGENT NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES OR MENTAL
ILLNESSES IN THIS COMMUNITY. HE
WAS A BELOVED MEMBER OF THE
SPACE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE AND OF THE SOUTH
BERKELEY COMMUNITIES A WHOLE. I
MET TO ME TOO WHEN I WAS
RUNNING FOR THE SEAT AND HE
INSTILLED IN ME. THE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE AT THE TABLE
IN EVERY CONVERSATION IN PUBLIC
POLICY. AND I'M SO APPRECIATIVE
OF HIS WORK I ASK THAT THIS
BODY DURING HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS WICKS. MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT THIS
MORNING TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF
JANE BOCKMAN. A TITAN OF
BUSINESS AND VOLUNTEER SERVICE
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
OF LOS ANGELES WHO SADLY PASSED
ON APRIL TWENTY EIGHT AT THE
AGE OF NINETY. JANE BACHMAN IS
SOMEONE WHO I SUSPECT WAS TOLD
AT A VERY YOUNG AGE THAT. ONE
PERSON SIMPLY CANNOT DO IT ALL.
AND THEN COMMITTED HER ENTIRE
LIFE TO PROVING THAT POINT
WRONG. IF SHE WASN'T FLYING
PLANES OR SITTING RACE CAR
RECORDS JANE WAS BLAZING A PATH
FORWARD IN OTHER WAYS. FOR MORE
THAN FIFTY YEARS JANE TURNED
HER PASSION FOR COMMUNITY INTO
A LASTING LEGACY. THROUGH HER
WORK SUPPORTING COUNTLESS SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN LOS ANGELES
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE VALLEY
ECONOMIC ALLIANCE. THE VALLEY
PRESBYTERIAN HOSPITAL AND THE
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY WHERE
SHE SERVED AS A DIRECTOR. JANE
BACHMAN'S DESIRE TO GIVE
SOMETHING BACK DIDN'T END AT
THE BOUNDARIES OF LOS ANGELES
THOUGH AND HER VOLUNTEER WORK
INCLUDED PROVIDING MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND HUMANITARIAN
RELIEF. IN EASTERN EUROPE AND
WEST AFRICA WHICH IMPACTED
COUNTLESS LIVES. IN THE VALLEY
JANE AND HER HUSBAND BURKE
BUILT. GALPIN MOTORS WHICH
TURNED INTO THE BEST SELLING
FORD DEALERSHIP IN THE WORLD
FOR NEARLY THIRTY YEARS. SHE
WAS THE FIRST WOMAN HONORED BY
THE VALLEY CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
WITH THE FERNANDO AWARD IN
RECOGNITION OF HER UNYIELDING
VOLUNTEER SERVICE. AND RECEIVED
A NUMBER OF OTHER HONORS
INCLUDING THE STAR OF THE
VALLEY FROM VALLEY ECONOMIC
ALLIANCE AND THE AMERICAN
BUSINESS WOMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS
WOMAN OF THE YEAR TITLE. IT
DOESN'T FEEL RIGHT TO SEE THAT
JANE IS NO LONGER WITH US
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S TRUE.
JANE BOCKMAN STORY IS WOVEN
INTO THE FABRIC OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FROM THE
INSTITUTION SHE STRENGTHENED.
TO THE LIVES SHE TOUCHED MORE
THAN THAT. JANE'S COMMITMENT TO
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY LIVES
ON IN THE HEARTS OF SO MANY.
WHOHOPE AS JANE DID TO LEAVE
OUR VALLEY. A LITTLE BETTER AND
A LITTLE BRIGHTER. THAN WHAT WE
FOUND. PERSONALLY I MUST. ADMIT
THAT. I WILL MISS HER SMILE.
AND EMBRACE SMILE. JANE BONTA
IS SURVIVED BY HER HIGH BURKE.
CHILDREN LOW VERNE THEY BRECHT
BRAT AND BOTH. AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING AND HER MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
MISSPELLED AYRSHIRE ALSO
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I ALSO
RISE AND ASKED THAT WE JOIN
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND JANE BOCKMAN WHO HAS
BEEN A LONG TIME SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY RESIDENT. AND REALLY HAS
PAVE THE PATH FOR SO MANY WOMEN
I'M IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORTING WOMEN
AND CHILDREN I FIRST MET JANE
WHEN SHE WAS A COMMISSIONER ON
THE FIRST FIVE LA COMMISSION
AND QUICKLY FOUND THAT SHE WAS
A WOMAN THAT CARED ABOUT
FAMILIES THAT CARED ABOUT WOMEN
CARED ABOUT OUR ZERO TO THREE
COMMUNITY. MY HEART GOES OUT TO
HER AND HER FAMILY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
INJURED AND MEMORY OF JANE
BOCKMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
HARRIS THANK YOU MEMBERS. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ON MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUE. SENATE HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS REYES MOVES MISTER FLORA
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY MAY
TWENTY FOURTH. AT ONE PM QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.